wie ist die Lage
Dr bedrohlich
weil «Ich habe keine Zeiten
für mich selbst machen
und das ist immer bedrohlich
seit wann ist das so
vier Wochen
vielleicht über 8 Wochen
vielleicht zwei zwei Jahren schon aber
was hat sich geändert das kann man nie
sein Terminkalender
Japan Tobacco Fürstenzell
Rituale an die ich mich gewöhnen Turba
frühmorgens
Prozent somit Sechser sie Morf zu
stillem einem Bademantel zu krabbeln auf
ein Rennrad zu steigen meint hierzu
waren vier Brötchen sowie Zeit und so
im Rahmen einer Bahre Montreal but i
Wanna Marwan
da gelten andere Gesetze als in der
Stadt mehr
und welche ich Liebe diese Gesetze also
dieses die situative wirklich zum
frühen Morgen
also eine konkrete Schätzung gelegen
das dann neue CD rausgebracht hat
plötzlich die Teilnehmer Sprecher der
Prozesse es wäre vermessen Ende
undankbar auch nebenbei gesagt also ich
finde ich finde es natürlich äußerst
kürzlich
das wird mal wieder hat er mit Bürgern
am Kapitalismus diese Gesellschaft
ärmer so ist es nicht
plötzlich wurde im zweistöckigen
Hotelzimmer wozu braucht ein Arsch dem
ich so ein Sonderegger
aber ich muss sagen Prozent ich bin auch
sehr dankbar dass
das ig-l Prozent Freunde gefunden aber
so fuhr ich natürlich meine
Plattenfirma
die Gesundheit Kirchens wurde immer
wieder müssen streicheln
Profile an der Kelter sozusagen also
schlussendlich werden ich führe und
schuf
wenn ich das nicht nach ein paar mal
entgegennehmen Post auch nicht wirklich
die Pleite
die Songs
das Buch
weil das Band dafür bin ich da dafür
Krystek
das ist mein Platz
in diese Landschaft
warum gab es früher keine
Streicheleinheiten
für
wann gab es das nicht ich habe mein
ganzes Leben lang bin ich jetzt zu tun
Google will passieren
was in meinem Leben so passiert es Ewald
Lienen 7 60 61
und durch das Buch kommt man plötzlich
man muss noch mal zurückkommen
was war denn der Indener Ecke der
Schublade Wasser
Ach da diese Sägespänen eigener dieser
Staub aus Wales normalen Strom war Weg
plötzlich merkte
eigentlich war es doch ein bitteres
Läden Abdi aber
in den Siebzigern hattest du einen Mega
Erfolg wer kann da einiges nicht
Nachsehen Hey Boss ich Brauch mehr Geld
oder Kommune meine Decke oder Juliane
Werding Bett kann jedes Kind wenn du
denkst du denkst du denkst du denkst
Jahr gut
ich möchte das nicht ungespült das war
natürlich Rückenwind Kiel dass ich
plötzlich
in den siebziger Jahren
der plötzlich dieser folgert aber die
Erfolge hatte mich aus dem stand
per er hat vor etwas getan
diese ganze Vorbereitung auf 70 und dann
die Hitze
von Arno Breker
dann bist du am Ziel heißt endlich
deine Erfolge
in Form von
wir wollen Gabel sehen wir wollen um
arm- und und und du bist aber nicht
wirklich
glücklich darüber dass Israel wirklich
so widerfahren darin denke heute immer
mal wieder mit Schrecken zurück ich war
nicht wirklich Happy Fernziel aber war
nicht mehr drin das war für mich das
bitterste
also erfolgreich zu sein heißt nicht
gleichzeitig in Frieden mit sich selbst
zu sein
also das was für viele Leute sagen wenn
ich erstmal eine Million habe dann wird
es mehr dann ist er überhaupt alle
Super und wer nicht das wird sie auch
dort seien ja Hopsten alles Super ist
und ich hab das verbreiterte voll mit
erlebt
es war trotz allem
nicht «super» ich war übermütig war
zeitweilig natürlich glücklich
allgemeine Halle gewesen plötzlich
konnten wir die einfach zu bezahlen oder
zwei Stück oder drei Ländern an aber
es war alles für mich ich habe
ich habe viele Falter das paar nicht los
so wisse trotzdem nicht so richtig
locker wie die anderen zum Beispiel
Sender Altendorf
Nein Nein deren Seiten saß und dass die
schrieben Maß sie wäre ich manchmal
die Tränen gekommen in Sachen ich hab
schon zu verpassen ich habs falsch
angepackt ich hätte etwas anders machen
können
Nolle das Fernsehduell Landau Mutter
darum bemühe mich nie trennen im Grunde
sind wir ganz andere Sachen Kündigung
Muslimen Super gut finde
Volvo durch
Fröhlich werden konnte weil ich auch
unfähig war das richtig einzuordnen
also
Prozent ich habe geweint Orange gewannen
32 da man diese
im Mittelteil
Ulrike Merten seiner Coe
dann fühlte sich verdammt allein
und dann setzte sich von rechts an den
zu schnell voran sein kann egal
und dann hast er Platzes einen Diesel
und das Geräusch dort und am 30
und er weiß dass ich zusammen
und gibt Gas und hat seinen Blick das
ist das sind das ist ja dieser
Schlüssel Mittelteil verbreitet oder
Diesel der sagt warum ist das Leben
eines trackers so Scheiße
also an diesen stellen habe ich immer
trennen brauchbar
ist die Musik
bei dir dann das Tor zur Seele
um
ich glaube schon ich glaube schon
jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet wo sich
früher nicht so Dr
Musik auf dem sowieso die Seele also das
nen beide Seiten ihr Land zu tun
feststeht
Musik
da öffnet gesehene und befriedigte ich
beachtlich Teppich
hat sich die die neue Platte befriedigt
weist
wenn man sie hört das ist ein anderer
Gunter Gabriel was hat sich verändert
also zum Beispiel ich bin ein nichts
das von den selber und das ist ja
offensichtlich stark autobiografisch
ich bin ein nichts
November müssen und wo nicht
wir dürfen nicht gemessen an
es geht ja immer darum
gemessen an VOX
natürlich sind wir nicht nichts
jeder ist seiner reinsten du bist eine 1
ich bin meiner 1
Kameramann ist ein 1
alle sind
jeder muss sich das mal selber lieben
aber im ganzen gesehen
gemessen an den ganzen riesigen
Universum sind wir ein Stau
die Erde
kein Staub
das ist natürlich darum nur so dass du
Mont
und Goethe diese diese Distanz zu sich
selber
muss man natürlich haben
also insofern
dieses ist dieser Song ich bin ehrlich
zu es ist phänomenal mir geglückt
Wales Prozent
weil es halt
ruhigstellen
und das war Mist Distanz
sich nicht überbewerten würde
und dann ist er für uns schon konkret
wer hätte gedacht dass
für das sie von Krebs und Sonnenuhr
setze das feuern sich das Konzert
von diesem Album auch Songs man von
anderen Leuten zu sein
warum sie das überhaupt nicht anders
aus als bisher was ich weiß dann wehrt
sich dagegen
in der Hitparade Waffen stammen Gas
das ist schon Schlagerszene gewesen und
das ist ja ein kleiner Eckpfeiler Moment
mal ich war in der Schlagerszene aber
ich meine
es ist dunkler unterschiedliche hier
mehr Industrie noch mehr nutzen
und ich sehe zum Beispiel
Pölten intercity-linie Nummer vier was
hast du nur gemacht was mir mehr
ich bin immer % Working men's
Personallage Chorsänger gewesener
also Prozent gut ich war in der
Schlagerszene weisen gab gar keine
andere Szene eher für Tesla
ich kenne ich keine wer als Perle im
Schalthaus WM auch ein Scheißhaufen
Leben
ich bleibe trotzdem immer bei mir
Whitesell für was ich mich ganz kurze
Runde Wasserhahn und dann ist die Chance
Weg und ich bin wieder Rick Perry r
also ich habe nebenbei gesundheitliche
Lage verschlechtert wird
immer musste mich immer Hilfe ich bin
dagegen bin dagegen
ich definiere mich halt anders werden
aber Prozent dieses Wachstums gewesen
und jeder the Help Desk eine Wendung
warum sich Che Non ist es keine wenn es
ist ja immer
der Mann muss natürlich sagen ein Teil
von mir gewesen er
durch dieses Urteil kann die zumal
ausprobieren
weil ich auch
da war ich auch niemand hatte der gesagt
hat das mach normal
es ist doch es ist doch immer so
für alles im Leben braucht die Gemeinde
St komm ich her stimmt
nur bisher nie erneuerbarer
das waren 2 9 Prozent
es war Prozent natürlich auch immer
dieses Quäntchen Glück
was dazu geführt hat Bild Zufälle oder
sowas also erstmal geht es ja darum dass
ich überhaupt erstmal gibt
so also singe Zahlen
Nandu Schlagerfuzzi ist mir auch
scheißegal was ihr zuhause
ich sage nur dass man muss sich ja mal
geben dass einer was a das ist doch der
der hat doch da da war doch mal was Wert
der ist doch gar nicht so bescheuert
wenn man so tut er
Sohn der Typ hat mich gefunden auf einer
Raststätte auf der a 3
diese bunte Geiselwinder Roth stellte
unter wie immer morgens früh Stück
country-pop mit Union Berlin Blume 400
Prozent du bist der Held meiner Juno
bleibe
prima Live mögliche Quartier
ich habe dann hingegen spielten
schönsten mal
ich hatte durch die Verdunstung und
Lustenberger
ich hab gedacht Nein
also durchgehend Erzähler Zeller
Zähler
wer das übliche und NT dann hat er wohl
nicht locker gelassen hat nicht locker
gelassen hat so kam 1 Prozent dass wir
uns trafen Hunderte Idee
mach du mal zweite mal die andere Seite
von ihrer
du bist so Liebermann der Pollen und
Mondou kann sondern besonders vorüber
über die Wirkung und zu sehen was sie
natürlich kann gleich
ich hab ihren Weichen Tal
und Hartmut Rall News aus
auch Bund sollte anders sein das heißt
du bist wiederentdeckt worden
wir brauchen auch Autobahnraststätte
Wien
so kann man also nur für ein Jahr
also wieder entdecken so viele Sonnen
Schloss Sa 2 ppm im Ohr unterwegs
ich habe immer Musik gemacht solange ich
Leben werden aber trotzdem extrem
erfolglos mit einem riesigen
Schuldenberg
in den letzten Jahren
aber so extrem erfolglose doch nicht
ich bin ich habe meinen Erfolg im
kleineren Bereich gesehen werde der ETB
Interesse oft viel viel liebenswerter
also dass
Walter Schmid Ebene kompletter Petrocca
der Paläste ganzen Quatsch worden
um er in die NBA ist das schöne im
Leben spielt sich ebenso wie Sohn nur im
kleinen ab
zu wenig sagen komm unter meine Decke da
passiert
und ich meine mich hier vom Büro von
Degen das meine ich gar nicht sondern
warm sein
mehr zärtlich sein
auf Wunsch 05 Uhr zum was weiß ich was
du willst ja
als das
es spielt Titel im kleinen ab von den
großen Run ist alles nur für
ich will nicht im hsv-stadion
unter Hunderttausenden Sitze nicht diese
zudem auf dem Lokus vom HSV
damit meine Ruhe Verstöße
und so sieht das nämlich außer am
besten sind sie sehr Erkenntnis gekommen
die Sicherheitshinweise die Berichte
zurück ich bin jedenfalls dazu gekommen
parallel dazu kommen wird weil sie
Ordner Super Jahre her
aber erinnern
ich bin jedenfalls dazu kommt fällt
hat das was mit der Situation um zu tun
in den Gedanken gekommen dass Krisen
Schulden auf dem Hausboot Leben
wo man dann einfach mit wenig zufrieden
sein muss
also Münstermann durch die Fakten dazu
gezwungen ja manchmal ist es war gar
nicht so schlecht bei aufgestaut
zufrieden hatte besorgt
das ist nicht leicht
nicht nur sage heute immer
mein Pech war mein Glück
dadurch wie das sich im Gespäch
Schleuderkurs kamen
muss sich kein bisschen malen das
Bundesland passiert
in dem Moment als ich merkte
jetzt bin ich auf platt
was heißt dass ich bin platt
ich kann mir nicht mal eine Zeitung
kaufen
ich kann meine Miete nicht mehr bezahlen
ich muss daraus ziehen
ich hab im Wohnwagen lebt mit zum alten
Ford Granada mit einer Anhängerkupplung
da habe ich geschenkt gekriegt
ich war platt mal Prozentpunkte
ich bitte um ein Freund der das alles
für mich vorbereitet hatte hatte mich
Bedrohung
und was dann
ich hätte mich auch erschießen können
natürlich aber ist das nicht zwar nicht
verbittert
Nein verbietet nicht warum ich in
Arenberg
weil Prozent
ich hatte am Anfang es gedacht dem
Schleimpilz Anaheim Cluster merklicher
ich hab ja nicht sondern nahm der ist
doch bayern-trainer Schweiz wie komme
ich denn Menge know-how wie MAZ in die
Schnauze Jahr
aber im inzwischen ist das so und es
müsste noch mal lernen
ich war das Arschloch
ich habe mir mit den Vertrag
unterschrieben aus Bequemlichkeit
ich habe mich überreden lassen
alles war meine Schuld ich bin ein
nichts
ich bin ein Versager ich bin ein Penner
ich bin ein Idiot gewesen
und die zu diesem Schluss das hat lange
gebaut
ist das jetzt mit Abstand setzt alles
schon
was Fernsehfilme Jahr 20 Jahre oder noch
länger
zu dem Schluss dass dort bis dahin
kommst
das ist Bauer Prozent zu
dass dort das gelte für jeden Menschen
einen Punkt zu kommen zu sagen was den
Pitch einführen
Idiot gewesen wäre
das ist Prozent
mehr heute kann ich das sagen
also insofern
ist doch toll dass sich
das ich so frisch geblieben wären doch
wunderbar dass ich darüber reden kann
und Sandra Boss auf Jungs hier jetzt so
kleine
Hosenscheißer noch sein da ich war
gestern auch so wie immer
ich kann als ein Pass auf rechts links
rechts links meine Kinder werden nicht
immer Sachen auf rechts ins Adorf
da kommt jetzt gleichfalls oder sogar
das war toll
als Person verkörpert davon galt da
wird man das
da seine Kinder so ein Bild zählt
Cordula setzt White White davor und
geben schon einsparen
Schnauze halten
das geht doch nicht ist das dein Kinder
Masken worden
aus allen aus all
aus allen natürlich ein
alle Kinder sind der verschiedenen
verschiedene Mütter haben
also
mal eine Gießkanne war überall zu
Hause so zusammen war die Blumen
gegossen
und ich bin heute
Prozent so könne wirklich erfüllt
da sich die Haare
Nein also
jedes Kind ist anders vom Charakter aber
immer ist so Sommer
14 4 4 Prozent gaben dabei und das ist
schon mal die Richtung
sie spricht leise Fernsehgespräch setzt
auch an die Scanner
du was oder wie es vielleicht noch
sexuelle Staat gehöre EURid sie jetzt
das heißt das gespielt für dich eine
große Rolle für jeden Menschen
um die Kraft des Lebens geboren wurden»
sagte Gül das ist ganz klar heraus aus
Mailand worden
also wer er werde
um dann schreibt man ist halt doch nicht
so geringen Mengen
denn das ist so wie Prozent der Sitze
bei den Zuchtbullen deren guter
Zuchtbulle guck dir mal an Hour
Werder war da los ist aber bei der Musik
die er nicht mehr los ich vermisse das
neun Prozent muss die klauen
besorge ich bin ja hier kein Macho Typ
ich Rede nur über die Dinge des Lebens
verstoße deshalb heißt das nicht dass
ich in 30 Zentimeter Oral oder
unter zehn Kilo Gehänge dass das meine
ich nicht ich Rede nicht davon
ich Rede nur davon
dass wir die Kraft des Lebens Ausbruch
aus der Sexualität kommen
ihr Haus aus der Natur unseres
unsere Seiten sehr
es gibt nichts Schöneres als das keine
Band legt kann wenn das zu geben
was mir die Schenkel einer Frau gehen
die Natur vielleicht gut riecht Uni
Dortmund und so weiter
dann Fußpilz hat und noch einigermaßen
durfte geworden und was noch besser ist
auch noch einigermaßen frisch renoviert
niemand kann das toppen
und das ist der Erhalt unsere
Zivilisation ist doch ganz klar
und dort dann muss man noch nie gehört
so eng wie unglaublich Schlauderer
Industry Co
und ich muss sagen
in allen Bereichen meines Lebens
haben Frauen gemacht die wichtigste
Rolle gespielt
und ich als ich zur APA was meinen sie
auch aber nicht nur
das back-up zu doch nur an uns was was
ist das denn für ein
aber gekonnt ist keine dieser Frauen
halten
Nein dazu bin ich gar nicht fähig
wenn das herauszukriegen und ob Braun
währenddessen soll die Frage ob man das
muss
also ich denke
es ist ja sehr lobenswert werden
heute als ältere Ehepaar die mir sehr
nahe sind darunter
ich bin vor 40 Jahre alle schon Phrasen
93 dazumal Rohr verlegt
über 25 Jahre was soll das zerrüttete
so lächerliche
Ilona nur zusammenzukleben aber nicht
mehr alleine sein kann
r also ist verschiebt sich im übrigen
auch nicht aber
ich muss sagen auch wenn du
in der Bitternis des Lebens lebst ja
auch wenn wir in der Beatle nächstes
Lebens lebst
Prozent
da gibt es keine gibt es sehr schöne
bei den Bochumern schönen diese Momente
dann sagte auch immer
diesen wunderbaren Satz Liebe ist das
Brot der Armen
Brigitte Satz weiter ich weiß es nicht
besser wüsste
Liebe ist das Brot der Armen
und die Ruinen der reichen
dann möchte ich lieber Arm sein das ist
klar
damit gehören sollen
und deshalb
fühl ich mich ob ich nun erfolgreich
bin mit der Platte oder mit dem Buch
immer noch
lieber Arm
weil ich dadurch Bereich bleiben
wenn du verstehst du 9
Zeolithe